well joining me now is Ricardo Latorre
National officer at fire brigades Union
Mr Latorre thank you for talking to us
at Sky News I'm sorry to hear of the
health conditions
um being faced by some of those who
fought the grenfell tower fire
um what do we know about the links
between that particular Blaze and the
condition that they're in
all right Samantha thank you for having
us these findings no this report will be
alarming for all firefighters reading it
and listening to it that we of course
don't know the exact ins and outs of the
Daily Mirror investigation but what we
do know is that from reports of our own
members and from they'd appear reviewed
research that we've commissioned
ourselves completely supports
the line of the report now that was
released earlier this week
um he showed that firefighters are
getting answers and much higher rate
than the general public and sadly
firefighters have died at a much higher
rate than the general public and they're
getting diagnosed with these answers at
a young age that completely supposed to
find this a World Health Organization
last year which categorized the
occupation of firefighting as
carcinogenic but I think what's most
alarming here and most scandalous is we
simply don't have the Protections in
place for firefighters domestically the
likes of which we see elsewhere in the
world America Canada Australia so we
need to seriously be asking the question
why we can't protect our firefighters
here in the way that we do in other fire
rescue services around the world yeah
and it's come down to the union hasn't
it to commission this report
um and it the report is suggesting that
it's not just a lack of ongoing Health
surveillance amongst firefighters but
that there is no routine monitoring for
exposure uh to to carcinogens
absolutely the evidence is now clear we
previously been told by government by
fire bosses there isn't enough data
domestically to support this link that
can no longer be said the evidence is
clear firefighters are dying young and
they're dying at alarming rate from
these diseases so our responsiveness
needs to be three stage we need the
proper preventative policies in to stop
our people getting these diseases in the
first place so these don't just include
cancers by the way we're Paul also
points to alarming rates of heart
disease and stroking firefighters as
well as mental health issues we then
need regular Health monitoring of our
firefighters like we see in other parts
of the world because we have a fire
fighters cancer and disease registry
that we are running together with the
University of Central act this year it's
a Mac incidence of cancer in
firefighters in the absence of anybody
else doing it and what he's telling us
is that firefighters I'm just getting
these cancers but they're being
diagnosed late um much more untreatable
stage so it's imperative that we put in
place proper National regular Health
monitoring of firefighters to catch
these diseases early and then ultimately
we need the presumptive legislation in
place that identifies these diseases as
occupational which is now beyond the
doubt so that firefighters can get
access to the financial and medical
support that they so desperately need at
such a difficult time of being diagnosed
with a cancer or disease as a result of
their work
I also read in the report
particularly as far as grenfell is
concerned the length of time that the
firefighter is wearing the protective
suit can also make their health outcomes
a lot worse and it strikes me that
that's something
um that where something could be done
quite easily
of course there's so much more that
Pharmacy Services can be doing is much
more than National Fire Chiefs Council
can be doing to help us mitigate and
prevent these risks as well the reports
are clear the longer that a firefighter
is subjected to these exposures the
higher the risk the longer that a
firefighter remains in their PPE their
Workwear the longer the risk so we need
to be putting in proper Deacon policies
and that includes being able to get
firefighters away from the fire ground
quickly enough so they can decontaminate
properly properly that is a clear
resource and funding issue there because
we have 12 000 less firefighters sat
here today than we did 10 years ago so
getting firefighters relieved and away
from the danger area is much more
difficult than it was when we had the
appropriate number of firefighters so
there is plenty that fire and Rescue
Services can be doing as well as
Government
and you're calling for various changes
are one of the most important it sounds
to me uh is the classification of this
um as an occupational hazard because
then that would create some sort of
um obligation for financial support what
if you don't get any of these changes
that you're calling for what then you
know we're absolutely calling for that
now we've previously taken studies
studies from the US studies from
Scandinavia to make these demands and
we've been told that they can't be
applied because they don't apply
domestically so in the absence of
government doing it in the absence of
fire bosses doing it firefighters have
gone away their cells and commissioned
and funded this independent research
that now provides the data domestically
it provides the evidence it provides the
research alongside the World Health
organization's categorization of the job
of firefighting as carcinogenic it can
no longer be denied and we need to
review the presumptive legislation so
that firefighter suffering from a cancer
or Worse dying from a cancer their
family doesn't have to prove that it was
caught at work because the evidence
points so clearly to the fact that these
are occupational diseases and now we've
been refused before in our demands for
these legislations and our demands for
the health monitoring we're now going to
be taking these demands Into the Heart
of government and we take them to the
National Fire Chiefs Council that have
been too silent and inactive on this
matter in our opinion now the entire
sector has to pull together and take our
demands to government to get the proper
protections the preventative protections
and then the medical and financial
support that firefighters so desperately
need I mean you'll struggle to fight
either that hasn't been affected by
cancer either directly or indirectly
Ricardo Latorre thank you very much for
talking to us on Sky News